des cours de physique chimie pour les
plus jeunes la maison de quartier
théodore monod de guyancourt a proposé
une activité d'initiation aux matières
scientifiques aux 7-12 ans au programme
plusieurs expériences ludiques
fabrication de circuits électriques et
de solutions chimiques avec des
matériaux simples de l'eau de l'huile du
sel ou encore des paillettes
l'atelier a permis de susciter des
vocations de chimistes ou de physiciens
voit ceux qui sont curieux qui
s'intéressent qui en savent déjà plus
que la moyenne et ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir aussi que c'est souvent
des filles ont plus on aurait tendance à
dire qu'ils sont des garçons mais les
défis sont aussi n'a pas la parité à
fonctionne très bien
transformation couleurs fumée les
résultats des expériences ont fasciné
les enfants je préférais les x les
expériences ils sont plus ou moins
dangereuses et si jérôme matérialise
aimerait bien la faire à la maison
au vu du succès des ateliers
scientifiques à la maison théodore monod
la ville de guyancourt envisage d'en
organiser davantage l'année prochaine